Paul you've also had a quite a classic
bad date yes I did when a couple of them
but one was really bad I was a double
date a buddy of mine and I went out with
two girls many years ago and the girls
didn't I think was pretty quickly
realized they were not that interested
in either one of us and we thought it
would be funny if we just started making
each other laugh and each guy kept
trying to outdo the other guy with just
silly things and when we were driving
home I was driving and I used to have a
jeep it didn't have the doors on it or
roof or anything like that and I was
driving I thought it'd be really funny
if while I was talking to my date who
was writing and the scene next to me if
I just stepped out I started running
alongside the car and I wasn't driving
fast obviously but even when you're
driving slow you can't it's really fast
she was talking some I just stepped out
of my car to run and I hit the pavement
so and I felt the tire kind of swoosh
past my house I looked up and I saw my
car going toward a tree and then it
stopped yeah because the girl that back
had to jump in the front seat and put on
the emergency brake my hands were all
cut up my hands were torn and I limped
back to the car and they were
ashen-faced and wondered what what did
and then we just drove home very quiet
did you pretend it to be in an accident
rather than oh I thought it'd be funny
it's right honestly there's no
explaining it would be funny if I
remember my my leg really hurt and when
I got home I used to have contact lens
contact lenses I had a contact lens case
and when I got home I took off my pants
and I saw the imprint of left and right
very excited for your appearance because
you were now mrs. Jonas well yes I did
get married
but now you had a Vegas which I did have
we got a picture oh now your wedding
photographer was Diplo is that right
well we didn't choose him to be our
wedding photography just kind of decided
to to livestream it okay Bernie what
happens in Vegas goes everywhere well
you aren't having a big party no oh no
it's not a secret but not anymore
[Laughter]
[Applause]
one of your old x-men he made a fuss
about your birthday Oh what's people
sent messages and they were invited to
do that and I won suddenly we've got a
cake and we're all together
[Applause]
yes you get to tell this story you tell
it yeah well I just saw the end result
suddenly onto the screen at my old
school I saw Hugh Jackman and 30,000
people and he was playing in Manchester
I was just eight miles away in Bolton
and they all sang happy birthday averted
to you with all these people
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
it is one of those companies where
there's lots of of improv going on I'm
guessing there's lots of improv going on
which you both enjoyed yeah I mean any
especially she enjoys when I like in
Sultan it's true yeah you're really good
at it she said very easy to insult I
mean I don't know it's just something
about your sincerity or something you
know what I'm not even argue with it I
know my favorite is when you called me
an animatronic [ __ ] on that day you
really look like you called me a big 2/3
Russell Crowe story that was like you
know Annie called me a big Taylor
Russell Crowe and this how did I make up
that you did
not many people know this Keanu Reeves
you trained as a ballroom dancer no I
didn't yes you did no no I took some
ballroom lessons not training um it
sounded like fun
I'm set to get walsim it was not Elise
it was thrilling actually I remember one
of the first lessons I had when I did
the waltz with the partner and oh my
gosh I mean I got high it was amazing
that first time doing a woman and she
bled and just it's like it was amazing
thrilling to be moving through space
like that you know yeah it was yeah
that's pretty special
did the foxtrot and some tango yeah
ChaCha and have you kept it off
absolutely no fun as it was you and - do
any of you wish to admit to having a
weird crush I'm might have had a weird
okay
pray it out basil broth
is true how's the wrong yeah a fox huge
tail yeah she fiery red strong teeth
does anyone in the audience have a weird
crush that they would admit to Phillip
Schofield that's not a weird crush
that's just a crush everyone loves pit
you oh thank you
she says Hugh Jackman
[Applause]
I sometimes think I'm huge
hey Spencer I mean you're an
award-winning producer three nominations
the win for the help and I do want to
read you another movie of yours again
Oscar no under hidden figures which got
you together to the White House there's
a picture and I think it's safe to say
octavia was quite happy to be at the
White House yeah
[Applause]
look at the picture box
he's saying listen they told us that the
president wasn't gonna come and Janelle
knew and so she was actually across from
me and I didn't think anybody was
watching us and I'm like there's not a
picture of Barack Obama looking you met
him when he was the president yes yes I
did you know I call him a bo personal
relationship no I did meet him and it
was funny I go to the White House and
the same thing he wasn't supposed to be
there and we go and say he might and he
comes out and I'm with my wife this is
actually a very very big moment for me
and my marriage because we're sitting
together and he comes out with oh he's
coming like that's him so we like move
up so we can be at the front because he
gives his speeches around the holidays
and he sees me and he goes uh-huh Kevin
Hart thank you for making time for me
coming to the White House love you we
love you and I said you got to be
kidding he looked at me and and I had to
plan so quarter to my wife I say but you
want to give me [ __ ] in the house
[Applause]
like she couldn't a knows who's gonna be
like I'm a chill and since that moment
is an ongoing joke that we have but that
day was a special day for me just to
hear him I mom meow and will are you
still first in line for the biopic
because it has hand-picked you wasn't it
yeah no we talked about it yeah yeah
that would be oh my god
[Applause]
[Music]